every year at comic-con there are a few
games that seem just perfectly suited
for comic-con and it's always a pleasure
to have them on stage and they always
seem to have this guy in front of him
Arthur Parsons and welcome to the stage
show all right pleasure to see you for
the third or fourth comic-con in a row
that's fantastic you're here to talk
about Lego Batman 3 beyond Gotham I am
indeed you guys of course TT games the
the Lego series just have done
phenomenal work for years and like
reimagining people's favorite
superheroes and little blocky Lego form
and Lego Batman 3 beyond Gotham is the
one you're showing off here today it is
indeed yeah it's it's it's the next sort
of step for for for the Lego Batman
series and what we're doing is we've
kind of shown people already then it's
going to space it's going as the tales
just beyond Gotham exploring the London
worlds but because it's comic-con
because it's the 75th anniversary of
Batman what we're going to show today is
something cool and quirky so you want to
see I am I am good with cool and also
quirky I like both those things okay
okay yeah so what we do is we'll start
the demo and I'll be quiet just while we
hear the first bit all right
our nefarious old foe that plundering
Punchinello of the Joker
once again the dynamic duo spring into
action to protect the good and true
citizens of Gotham
yourself Boy Wonder those are
military-grade Paul's not for fun or
recreation to the Batmobile Robin we
need to put a stop to that grinning
devil but wait where there's her trusty
transport that abominable outlaw he's
hit us below the belt even the Batcave
is not safe from this contemptible
crimes quickly Robin we must rebuild our
crippled conveyance so obviously this is
what I remember Batman
yeah I watch the reruns growing up you
ask anyone and they'll all say that they
love associate Adam West with money and
so the first thing on the kind of like
the crazy sheet with what we call it
everything's will do yes get to the
third Lego Batman game your IRA we need
to start we've said we've set the stage
we've covered our bases let's get wild
yeah absolutely yeah because we've got
this epic story into space
Justice League Legion of Doom all kinds
of crazy going on and then it's like
what else can we do where else can we go
and it was like you know what once you
finish the main story and yet you're
exploring sort of the main hub world why
not in the Batcave have a little hidden
area where once you're the story's
complete your keys unlock it slide down
the pole boom step back in time you get
a replay and we'll recreate the 60s TV
classic so you know we're gonna have
Batman we're gonna have Robin it's all
in the racism voice by Adam West which
is some of the funniest video work I
think I've been involved with that's for
sure and then it's you know it's all the
great stuff from the show you know you
can run around with a bomb
you've got the like the stings the power
bands classic dililili oh it's all there
just to I guess introduce this to a
younger audience they don't know what
this is
mm-hmm but all the mums and dads will
and that's
and that's the cool thing it's that
bringing something that we know to a
whole new audience and I gotta say it
seems like you know like the Lego take
on Batman is already a little bit a
little bit whimsical a little bit sort
of lenience that the fun well a lot
leaning into the pod Batman and the
original the Batman series was also kind
of like that so it seems just like the
perfect match yeah like in tone and
especially given Adam West's recent
comedic voiceover work
yeah that he's been doing it it seems
just like a real natural fit yeah
absolutely and and for us it gives us
that sort of extra dimension with the
game because we always try and add as
much as we can possibly get in a game
you know aside from the story and then a
huge cast of characters and then like
with this one we're going out and
exploring hub worlds lantern worlds as
part of the hub so you know places like
xamarin or or a car some kind of crazy
places in the DC Universe so it's kind
of nice as well to have something that
that people wouldn't have necessarily
expected obviously they will now because
we've shown them but when you're
actually playing the game it's just that
nice little aside and just like whoa
that was a bit of a curveball I didn't
really expect that and and it's just
great as well because it kind of brings
all that together and like you say fun
Lego games are about fun what's more fun
than than the 1960s Batman and yeah as
well as that it's the Batmobile that I
loved the most and and we've always kind
of had that you know in our minds can we
get an A in the game can we get that in
the game is like well yes we classic
yeah so yeah this this this section is
is kind of like this is there's a few
sections of this the first section is
about we'll hold on where is that
trustee trustee transplants but where is
the Batmobile and so you have to go
around smashing stuff up there's some
comedy lines in there from from Adam s
saying oh yeah well you know what they
actually hide spare parts in bits and
pieces of the black cave just in case of
emergencies and then you can go ahead
and build it and it looks so good in
Lego form
if you have one on your mantelpiece at
home already I don't but I do now
because I actually got one here at
comic-con oh really
yeah one of the little little ones so
yeah I'm definitely taking that home and
and again this is like this sort of
level we're going to be showing more of
this stuff oh we've got our own panel I
doubt if you know but on Sunday at 1:00
p.m. Adam West and then some of the
great voice casting ever do this voice
cast is in the main game you've got Troy
Baker you've got Travis Willingham Laura
Bailey Dee Bradley Baker you got Scott
Porter it's just the cast is immense so
we've got load of those guys coming for
the panel at one o'clock so and there
were more reveals there but what we're
also going to show here because
obviously this is just a tiny part of
mega game is some some cool new DC
characters this Lego Batman 3 has the
most characters that we've ever done in
in a Lego Batman game so there's a
little snippet here but ultimately is
gonna be over 150 well you guys are no
strangers to Lego game is packed with
giant rosters of characters so you know
the when we've talked before these sort
of deep cuts of you know in the Marvel
Universe and the Batman universe they
end up surprising even you guys and you
end up learning about some of the stuff
that real passionate fans you know
already know about yeah yeah absolutely
so you know here we've got Blue Beetle
who I'll be honest before working on
this I wasn't aware of this character
mm-hmm but we had people contacting Lego
batwing game on social media and just
being like ombliboo tombliboo and so
obviously we're like well okay let's
research this a little bit blue beetles
got a social media follow you know and
you read into like the the history and
there's this kind of like weird scarab
beetle thing that the attaches to a
spine and like whenever is in danger
forms this arm around them and conform
like weapons and it's just like wow it's
really cool you know let's get him in
the game so you know obviously we put
Blue Beetle in the game and like the
cast we have at the minute is you know
that we've revealed he's real just a
little snippet of what we've got so far
but as well as Blue Beetle we've also
got character
I think yes we've got Miss Martian who
we haven't had in a videogame before and
again you read into the history of this
character and it's great you know the
character is created by Geoff Johns and
and there's like a whole backstory as to
why the character is created and and so
for me as a as a designer II it's really
exciting and interesting learning a
little bit more about what these
characters do and who they are and and
as well just how passionate some people
are about characters that you wouldn't
really believe you know deep in in this
roster so if we bring up the roster and
we see we've got him here we've got back
out now back out was rescued that cat as
yeah rescued from a slaughterhouse it's
like I don't think you know I don't know
I was just taking about this is one of
the guys in the office is you've got to
get back now yeah I feel they're winding
me up okay so but no right show you a
comic a genuine DC comic with bat cow
how's that okay you know we'll run with
that and yeah how doing his job kicks
yes some kind of weird lunge attack
which you know what we'll roll with it
yes it's cool but yeah you know in that
assignment down to your animator right
oh yeah we need you to our animated cow
to do our some Batman type attacks go
ahead all the way down I was the first
to thing that I was being wound up I
then talk to the other guys they think
this is one elaborate prank you're
pulling on on yeah absolutely but then
you know ya back has not the only animal
within within the roster we've also got
crypto you know you know Superman's best
friend rather than man's best friend and
again crypto can do the abilities that
you'd imagine your laser eyes on flying
and it's just such a cool thing to be
able to put in you know as well as your
Joker's and your Lex's and your Batman's
and Robins and you know Green Lantern's
and all the characters that you know
they really get all the limelight to be
able to dig deep and sort of go
throughout the entire universe of DC and
in talking of which and then play as an
animated Lego dog yeah there's also the
base level of that thing looks adorable
that is a grounding
and then obviously these characters as
well they take part in loads of quests
around the the open world so that's
really exciting and fun but yeah we've
also got lego big figures in the game
again so in here we've got one of the
lanterns we've got our kylo who is just
immense yeah that's my dude and and
doing a big elbow drop yeah exactly you
don't really want to be getting in this
guy this guy's way but he flies you know
and it's you use a feather you really
you read through the the sort of like
the the stats and the information about
these characters and and we have to then
recreate them as best we can because you
know every character what we pride
ourselves on trying to faithfully
recreate and and and and visit them and
make sure that they're the best they can
be and as a part of that sort of the
research you guys do you also if I'm not
mistaken bring some of that you know
like if people can read about that in
game they can learn about these
characters in the game as well so that
when they select bat cow alright
telltale TT games is pranking me there's
a bad cow they can read up on it and
sort of yeah that knowledge yeah cuz you
know throughout throughout the game with
some of these characters there are there
are known and loved characters but you
know when you dial down to like the
younger audience they're gonna know
Superman yeah they're gonna know Batman
they're gonna know Flash they're getting
those cyborgs because they're you know
they'll they'll they'll have seen him in
maybe 10 times or something like that
but then some of the other characters
they won't know so it's almost like a
duty that we've got to introduce these
characters to a whole new audience you
know the great thing about superheroes
is that that they transcend generations
and yeah we're really hoping that with
Lego Batman 3 it's it's kind of the
ultimate superhero movie for the whole
family this year is something that
hopefully everyone can enjoy together
what's greater than like you know as a
dad being able to pass on your knowledge
to you know your son your daughter and
you just keep that going here solomon
grundy you know you look for these
characters that with this Hawkman
there's you know mix ears pick like
great character yeah he can defeat
Superman what's cooler than that
even though he looks like some kind of
weird little goofball absolutely
lounging but again a great character and
characters like mixi and and bat-mite
again people just love these characters
yeah there's a lot of love for the wider
DC Universe Blees is a great help my
goodness those wings constantly fury you
seen anybody does anyone do lego hero
cosplay here have you spotted anyone I
haven't I am actually gonna be walking
the floor for the rest of the show
trying to find some Lego cosplay there
usually is some which is great I did see
someone dressed as as mixer as pit like
yesterday which was brilliant because it
was kind of like it was one of those
cosplays that's not really very good but
it's he's that bad that it becomes
brilliant and they're my favorite you
came back around yeah absolutely you've
gone full circle and become awesome but
you know Plastic Man he can transform
into loads of crazy things and one of
his finishing moves again we delve deep
into the comics in one of the comics he
actually transforms into a toilet grabs
a bad guy down the toilet flushes him
away as far as him - nobody knows where
yes I'm a stick man sewer somewhere and
obviously you know Adam West as well as
playing Batman 66 he's in the game as
himself and he's the imperil character
so whenever you're going round the
levels or the the open-world
you're gonna be hearing Adam West yeah
and and you're just rescuing him from
all the lantern worlds where his managed
to get himself into trouble
absolutely but the the lines of
brilliant he was such a great sport so
it's just like you can just hit help
help it's me TVs Adam West you know come
on rescue me and it's so funny you know
that that voice recording session was
just it was one of those highlights
where you just like yeah yeah I'll be
telling that to the grand but you know
the game itself in terms of characters
you know like Billy Batson he can
transform Tisha's am and we've really
looked you know but Lego Batman series
like about one and two have been
phenomenally popular and we've just gone
you know what let's really just push it
up the ante up the ante in the main
story the character roster the
animations the vo
just really go all guns blazing to make
this a really epic game for this year
and I think people are gonna absolutely
love it well they certainly will here at
comic-con with this roster you having
together have got in here you've got a
panel coming up on Sunday
we definitely have a one o'clock room
six BCF all right and yet there's some
crazy cool announcements and some epic
giveaway so it's gonna be really good
very cool well we'll be certainly
passing along those announcements here
on GameSpot for those you who are not at
comic-con and Arthur I think that this
has been it's always fun to chat with
you about these games because you even
you know you're not a Blue Beetle me on
a Blue Beetle yeah you do now and you
there's this joy in discovering these
characters that you're talking about and
it's just so fun the way that you guys
continue to sort of mine these fertile
grounds for for delightful experiences
like this yeah yeah really good fun well
Arthur thank you so much coming by and
talking about Lego Batman 3 beyond
Gotham young beyond Gotham uh and also a
big thanks to your daughter Lily for
driving the demo here absolutely yes
doing a great job and so you're you know
comic-con as game developer you've done
comic-con as fan house comic-con as
parent marginally scary oh yeah yeah
it's just like yeah where are you but as
well as like it's the joy of just seeing
our eyes just like wow everywhere
everything's just like boom boom and it
makes comic-con that exciting awesome
experience all over again because I'm
seeing it almost through her eyes so
yeah it really doubles the enjoyment
factor well big thanks to the Parsons
for coming by much appreciated
good luck at the panel and enjoy the
rest of the show that's Lego Batman 3
beyond Gotham actually did we say what's
when this game is coming out the games
coming out fall in the fall yeah so you
can pre-order it now loads of awesome
pre-order incentives out there and yeah
he's ps4 ps3 xbox 360 xbox one pc mac
3ds Vita Wii U you know you've got a
console you can play that's pretty much
a comprehensive lineup right there the
elds my superior game yeah it's gonna be
epic alright thanks again Arthur Lego
Batman 3 ladies and gentlemen